okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about incremental
language development form of language
and we have a variety of topics today
let's start with Korean reversed so this
is another iteration a sign of curry are
reversed which are very close to each
other so what we agreed last time was
the first lines of each of them so
effectively that yes that reversed would
take two arguments and then it will be
generalized to move the arguments which
is a very useful thing but then by the
way I assume that we like the word
reversed and we don't prefer something
like swapped to avoid the confusion with
with reverse itself I do like reversed
because swapped seems to suggest and
this is actually quite nice okay so that
that's a good idea
yeah that's cool yep that is cool
indeed because many people sometimes say
oh I want the opposite convention for
this product and so is it that noise so
that's a good thing and that's why I'm
still suggesting we go that route but in
discussing with Rahman he is still
unhappy that the default of curry F is
reversing the argument so something he
suggested is the last line of the first
section which is that instead what we
could do with the one argument curry is
to carry curry itself
I understand so that would be an
alternative which I understand is kind
of very clean from the theoretical point
of view but then the problem is and then
how do we do what we currently do with
courier faith and that's a third section
why doesn't it just reversed well isn't
that the same thing well we want
something that is Cara ball because
curry of whatever will then be used in
curried form with just one argument and
we were not planning to carry reversed
that's a problem we can we can either
carry it or make it work but not both
things I understand
okay so we just understand something so
if I say Curry of f of X of Y it's gonna
be F of Y of X Y acts like that right
all right it's do we have a version of
reserved reversed it's runnable know but
it's sorry I always forget to send you
desi
his courage still Tigers experimental
yes it is
and precisely why that's why we are
still discussing its basic design
okay so reversed of f of X of Y turns
into F of Y X but it's not curable
because being ver arc we want it also to
work on zero and one arguments so we
cannot save reversed of f of X and of Y
right so that just does that exactly
okay okay so now what's the but so I'm
confused by curry of f of X Y doesn't
curry of f of X what the hell why is it
going to improve oh why doesn't that
just turn into f of X why am i am i
confused here no because curry of f by
default expects two arguments so it's
they are waiting for the second one okay
so or just one just at least okay so
okay
proposal here it's a matter of a choice
we either change toward romances of
curry of n of F but then then it becomes
difficult to construct operator forms or
we'll keep it as it is with the reversed
being varrock which would we were
waiting waiting I mean the the curry
fact that um we are reversing these
arguments in the curry it's far from
obvious that that's correct I mean I
mean it could be that the default curry
um is you know the fact that the default
curry reverses you know it could be the
default curry think we have considered
is curry - yeah that's equivalent to
curry F comma - yeah and then it takes
the two arguments and do not that's not
so slow what is going on here I have
seen this recently can you can can you
do dollar context
this thing is discount punkers look what
is happening
but you cannot even write no it's got a
spinning disk I'm gonna try and correct
this maybe this kernel that got confused
for some reason that is truly bizarre it
says the product the it says the thing
isn't running but yet it still has the
notebook up on the screen that's really
weird I've never seen that before it's
kind of a Twilight Zone thing it's how
could that oh I see what's happening oh
my gosh oh my gosh
how utterly confusing um never mind
what's happened is that this is running
in some totally bizarre prototype build
never mind okay bye bye to that hold on
and that also explains that weird
aborted thing that we saw at the
beginning okay let's let some okay let
me also get your definition of reversed
oh come on what the heck that is
refusing to let me paste what is going
on there
weird weird how Devin could you report
that this was a pasting
next interfere which I think may be
similar to the problem of pasting images
that sometimes fails yeah as I've
experienced the same problem in the past
I mean I think John I had said something
about maybe he said he found it I
forgotten I cuz I gave him some cases um
okay all right we're looking at um okay
so why do we think curry reversing is
particularly useful
I mean if curry because the vast
majority of our operator forms do that
they carry the second argument example I
mean so for example select yeah select
courage second argument I was using one
example like transpose it was the
natural thing they are to transfer to
courage the permutation yeah well to
curry as in to put as the I mean the
natural thing is is curry of transpose
whoops curry transpose of to one for
example of matrix yeah I kind of agree I
mean I'm we don't have Roman on this
call to me I mean this is clearly a
useful operation what's going on here is
clearly useful operation and he
understands that I think his point is
that there could be a dedicated operator
for that but I have any person that's
going to be too many and I don't see
even though I see the beauty in curry N
of F he didn't send me an example of
something that that uses that what about
this what about something cookery too
that just does the swapping thing I mean
let's try to name we obviously had a big
hard time naming curry but what if we
were just trying to name this operator
the one that picks up um at some point
we had a curry swap I think
it's pretty obscure I mean what's the
analog of reversed that could do this
you know reversed means that it's taking
its arguments reversed so I think our
problem is that we need a combination of
reversed anchoring and if we separated
things as Roman wanted we would have to
combine them as you see at the very end
of your mental cranium yeah I understand
that's horrible
so we need a name to this thing okay so
what is it really doing I mean look
that's what we call it all the time it's
a bit unfortunate because it's not
traditional but but yeah it's what I
call it yep I think this is too general
is that a thing with upper you know
great don't we I think that's very
general what the heck is all right it's
not head oh gosh this is one of these
version1 functions that has never really
panned out the way I remember this
function is by changing to Muppet head
maybe we should call it Matt bat head
and retire operator after long service
of 30-something years because I agree
that I will never remember this thing I
mean I didn't remember it um
is there an operator form of operate and
I think so that seems mildly interesting
actually that that operator form don't
you think
we do have a better forms for all the
cows since Marvin I'm sorry Exeter I
know so okay I mean I I think we should
seriously consider having a map at head
and deprecating operation maybe a lot of
20 years we can reuse the name but at
the very least if we were still going to
use operate we should make operate have
an operated form okay but here
something to take into account is that
if we have a dedicated operator form
object similar it will need the same
freedom of Curie because sometimes we
want an apparent form of the second
I'm sure absolutely so it's what we've
basically like currie but with a
different default well no it could be it
could be exactly like the Curie we have
now I mean it could be it could be that
we actually renamed our current curry
has operator form and then maybe make
curry do the Roman thing I mean this
would make for some reasonably readable
code I don't really like the word form
yeah it's unfortunate um what else could
we do what other ending for operate
could we have
okay so what we would explain here is
that this is oh look at that represents
an operator form of the function f Lukas
on our live stream is saying that
operator forms do not exist for map all
and block map that's kind of dumb that
seems like an oversight
why are an operator form not exist form
at all yes we have been adding them one
by one and block map all and block map
um okay so let's come back to this I
wish this could be slightly shorter
operate okay so what would the code look
like so what we'd have is
you know we'd have something like this
you
you know we haven't used the word
operator in 30 years what do we think
about this is a possibility so it's
scary such a general name but it reads
very well yes and I'm thinking if one
day we introduced operators then we
would have a conflict with operator
forms actually what kind of operators
say differential operators so things
that it's a bit like a generalization of
derivative one yeah something that can
combine differential operators without
actually applying them to a function or
something like that
yes it might be in the future of any
source
no I agree I agree to be able to create
a differential operator but how would
that differential operator work I mean
it will be a thing I mean making curry
be something that is very pure istic
like having this crazy you know like
like having it you know having its one
argument form be it scurried you know be
it a self curry seems seems kind of
reasonable given how you know how funky
the function is to begin with
yes it's it's it's a fewer version now
for example it's a it's a version that
cannot have defaults in number of
arguments because having an empty pair
of brackets but sound strange there yeah
I don't know what the default would be
anyway right
I mean this is one of the many you know
Kluge's of lambda calculus and so on you
have to know how many things you're
collecting I just have this one I'm just
wondering if there might be some
mathematical you know I know that that
means something different but but some
other you know operator like name that
isn't operator
um let's see
well write provisionally I'm beginning
to think caravan makes sense
and that we need something here that
that you know reflects
[Music]
yeah actually I Lukas on our live stream
is is suggesting something this is this
an auto function auto that's an amusing
idea I'm so scared of Auto functioning
functions because of some disasters that
happen in S&P with those things but the
concept here would be that I mean it's
semantically quite kind of weird but I
mean in in other words if you had an F
of let's say it was you know at sign
hash b-but that would essentially auto
function eyes this thing okay what I'm
saying yes but not one argument it's
it's the it's some mean that would then
be equivalent to this the problem
soon as you wrap another function around
this this is gonna go to hell right I
mean as soon as I do this it's gonna
wind up being G of F of that and it's
gone to hell I do agree I mean I mean
for example um yes Ethan is pointing out
that something like this already exists
with very beautiful
I mean Christopher is a big enthusiast
of this way of writing function which I
agree looks very nice
that's solving a slightly different
problem because this is this you still
have to name the variable alright are we
well let's think about how the
differential operator um how would the
differential operator work there will be
a symbolic thing that represents that is
like a derivative and that would
presumably if applied as a sub value C
but this is exactly where my hole
through and operate and all those guys
came from right because through what I
imagined was that one would say things
like you know D plus 1 of X ok and then
it one would say things like through of
that and one would get this right I mean
that was intended to think about
differential operators that live you
know operators that live in the head and
that have arithmetic going on with them
and so on
yes disappears sometimes in the calculus
of derivatives for example so you have F
Prime and G Prime and it's not easy to
convert to construct a single function
that can be then applied to X sure right
well I think we should um
Nathan on the livestream is mentioning
things about the scope constructs from
general utilities which I do not know
anything about does anybody here know
about those don't good thing for us to
look at I don't know about them scope a
module scope I'm Devin maybe you could
add those to some okay anyway so look
that the one question here is are we do
we want to call this operator I don't
know I think that's too general
well come up with another suggestion I
haven't that's the problem I almost
would prefer operator form to operator
no I agree what no I I do to other than
that your mouth often has a different
meaning in the language I still would
prefer that right my question is is
there any other ending for opera at so
to speak operating operate operated
reversed I mean I was wondering about
operators I don't think that quite works
yeah I mean unlike reversed which does
work I mean the fact that
human tation says operator form is a
little hard to escape
well search either operator or operator
form okay so I suggest that let me try
to implement this this new version of
curry for next week and see if it all
works correctly fine and we'll give us
more time to think okay
um okay sander has been talking about
operator forms apart I think we may get
to that well let's take a look what he's
saying here yes I agree with what you're
saying about about um I mean I hate the
hash sub-2 thing so the question is what
is you know if you say you're giving the
example hash sub 2 amperes and what
could be the operator form of part we
have extract - yes and that can extract
this second element but it's not very
generalizable Sanders complaining that
it doesn't support all and span why
doesn't extract support span well
extract was and this is the discussion a
day in the last topic thread was created
as an inverse to position and so
additions have been a later thing
all right okay when we get to the
inverse support let's discuss the
operator fall apart
um I agree that an operator form apart
would be very nice problem is and you
can't use part itself cos fare args and
it needs to be something shorter it's
not going to be useful
you
I wish there was an ending for part
the word part which could be an operator
version carry of part was another what
do you mean Currie like this yep now you
can say - ethan is saying that there is
actually an entity class courier bull
from language symbols I didn't know that
and that there are 93 of them I didn't
know that it been curated interesting
well we should make sure as an LCC thing
that we've actually got but this is
consistent and that we have all the like
all the things on the map family here
mm-hmm
likewise can not courier ball oh it is
okay and Korea's Korea ball yes I guess
it is yeah there's a
this function and the function
repository I know hum oh this is a good
point from ride on our livestream that
it would be more sensible to call curry
curried than curry
yeah I'm not I'm not claiming Lukas is
saying the courier part of 2 is ugly and
I completely agree with that
should it be curry or curried given that
it's reversed it sounds I'm so used to
carrying out that yeah curried sounds
Wilton oh that may be so obscure I mean
the whole thing is so obscure if you
unless you know you know somebody sees
this and it's like unless you know the
whole story of you know the lambda
calculus story basically it's just an
extremely obscure name um which is why
it'd be really good to have this common
thing we called operator or something I
wish there was another ending
well maybe we should try this okay all
right let's keep going here okay next up
fold while yes so here the discussion
was whether to return the last
successful case or the first failure
case and we decided to look at some
examples okay and the truth is that
looking at the examples it seems well
you might still want either fantastic
okay okay I have the person is slightly
more useful to know the first failure
case because at least in fold while list
you get both back
what does while do while returns
effectively while takes an action and
then stops taking the action and returns
nothing right yes it's like do by the
way the typesetting of this is really
sucky and what does take while do take
while returns only the successful cases
and that's one of the problems that the
precedent of tech wall is the opposite
as the percent of nest while ok what
does nest while do it is it on stairs
first failure because because nest while
otherwise if the first thing failed then
it's got to return you know an empty bag
type thing right that's the third point
is there subsection there I mean can we
parameter
having it returned as the second section
if you open the second subsection their
final result will be 2 divided by 2
count
yeah I was trying to find cases in which
we would use there and I think this is
useful to construct something limited by
size you know I agree for example and
this is a bit like run down it's like a
random walk with your paths based on
something that Michael constructed
you
it's amusing okay so what do you want in
this case I mean it's hard to know in
this case but the min/max computation
shows that we indeed went beyond the
circle and I think that's the use of a
thing to know to be able to prove that
you went beyond equally well say you
know it could be that there are dragons
beyond the circle you don't want to go
outside yes but somehow this is a
confirmation that we did otherwise how
do we know that the next that's what I'm
I was saying in any case you could
always say I want either of them
there's no way to edit in the criterion
yeah I don't see how how does this
relate to doesn't um nest while have a
have a thing that looks back at a
certain number of previous it has a way
of presenting a certain number of
previous some results right we
introduced sequence for no it supplies
the M most results yep now doesn't fold
this fold have a no fold obviously
doesn't need a I mean fold has a
template for how far to go because
that's in the gens but by the way I
don't understand unfold you can allied
the seed argument yes you can whereas
here you cannot we were planning to do
it as well just like counting
tournaments and because it's different
from restructuring yeah all right
you
people on numb yeah Lucas is saying they
prefers nest well but it's more similar
to fold while I agree with that
um I often apply most to the result of
full well list yeah
nest while can return the enth the last
element as well
I see so that's in fact doing the exact
same thing here that's got an argument
exactly like that when you're proposing
you
an extra end time so what does that do I
see that's very good
an additional end times after test fails
but now yeah okay so it's equivalent to
this well I think that's probably going
to be the winner here and the default
should follow yeah yeah it's a six
argument function it's horrifying um I
mean it's always
some of these you know one kind of piece
of modernization that we could do on
some of these many many argument
functions like partition and so on is to
have an alternative form where there's
an association much like we didn't sell
a row Thomson well there's an
alternative form where you can just name
everything I don't think that will be
terrible I mean that's oh that's an LCC
activity to try to do that for some of
these functions with you know lots of
different tentacles here so long as
there's an actual name for the arguments
if there's no name for the arguments
it's hopeless
alright so listen I think the right
thing to do here is um have this last
argument it's got to have the same
meaning as in this case which means the
default is zero I think if I'm not
mistaken right the default is and
additional end times after test fails
okay all right next random integer with
the step yeah I was suggesting this
seems very clear and the only concern is
the fact that it cannot be extended to
other cases because I don't think this
can be used in their in their continuous
case no but why would we worry about
that I mean why wouldn't it work in the
continuous case I mean that this is
equivalent to saying random choice of um
you know it's basically range you know
one point four seven point eight in
steps of point three and then it's a
random choice of those I don't see why
that wouldn't work it's a very different
meaning from random real okay you're
right you're right it's a continuum and
this is not a continuum
well I mean that's the question what
does random real I mean random real what
do you think here so I I think we should
simply perhaps have a possible issue or
property and relation example explaining
the difference that in the same way that
we have our range with the three
arguments that is discrete we don't have
a who cannot have a range for the
continuous case it would be an interval
yeah so it is a random real of interval
work probably should nope that should
probably work um okay okay
random complex is hopeless okay random
crime that's an interesting one because
I mean one could indeed want two primes
of the form 3n plus one or something do
we have any control and primes
well I mean it's kind of stupid to have
any third argument there is means that
it's a multiple of that third argument
right unless it's so I mean you could
have a weird case right well no actually
if it's three unplanned amok it would be
the thing if we say one comma you know a
hundred comma three right that will be
Prime's of the form 3m plus one I don't
that's kind of crazy just to yeah by the
way I was just playing around with
random real with working precision sort
of has the effect that you of
granularity that you if you've got
sufficiently low working precision yeah
I tried it worth working precision to
for example yeah it's a little different
though it's still a continuum yeah
granular coarse continuum but yeah sure
I guess
among other things that means one can
already do this sort of thing it's not
something we really need to try to do
Hamm Springs to introduce yeah right
okay let's talk about random primes
okay and whether we care about having
random primes of the form you know 7 n
plus 2 and things I mean clearly I don't
know how random prime works but I would
suspect that it can much more
efficiently generate I mean you know
whatever its candidate how does it
generate candidate primes
does it just pick a number and see if
it's a prime I think for large ranges
yes and for small ranges it probably
picks a number in a certain way and then
cause Prime on that okay and my vague
recollection is that it was implemented
in such a way as to get the distribution
roughly uniform
I see the natural application of the
problem somehow yeah yeah the just using
that as an asymptotic yeah I'm not sure
it was implemented that way I merely
have this vague recollection that I
think it was
well it claims not basically well I
should have been well what if you ask
Charles I could be the person for that
now yeah I think was implemented by
Darren way back when Klaus Meyer okay I
thought it was um okay so I'm sorry
let's go back to random prime so I mean
there's a question of whether Prime
itself should allow some okay the step
argument is not gonna happen in private
in random crime doesn't make any sense
there's a separate question where the
prime should allow some kind of selector
that says you know Prime's of the form 3
n plus 1 or something
my guess is it's not that common a need
and people who need it we're not going
to be able to offer anything that's
other than syntactic sugar here what is
the criterion in the RSA algorithm for
example there's a criterion on the
primes I can't remember what it is I
don't remember either
there's something beyond size that it
come on yeah like like P plus 1 can't be
smooth or something you can't have small
divisors or something like that or P
minus 1 or both
um I I think it it is some criterion of
the primes have to be able to form
something rather something or other
anyway that will be nice to know because
that's a case where we certainly use
this
you
oh well there's a notion of a safe prime
why P minus 1 over 2 is also prime
it's interesting okay
well it sounds like an interesting
function repository function
um
let's suggest that
I'm sure repository save prime not that
we ever want to call a function in the
main system safe private are it's
promising too much
okay so that may be the clutter in there
um okay first people on a live stream my
mentioning Ethan is mentioning forgot
about uncaring impartial functions will
be super cool to do category theory
almost language itself yes well what
does uncarrier do
a partial function of
stakin is the kind of thing we already
have right a minute something like like
this where they full function
yeah I mean the the partial function is
just curie of
f comma three for example and until it's
until it's been fed enough it doesn't
write until it's it's some what does
uncarrier do incur a would turn go from
this to f of X of Y of V right I agree
that with that is a missing function I
think if we said uncor a oh boy
XYZ we can imagine that going to f of X
of Y of Z we discussed this at some
point and our conclusion was that
because we don't usually then evaluate
this type of things in general we really
really need it do you remember that we
were discussing like patterns for any
number of brackets and functions to how
many brackets you have yes yes so it's
these would require some sort of
completely new set of functionality in
our case right well we what we would
want is the curried function analog of
repeated right of double blank for
example sayings any any depth of Carine
at some point yeah no I know and it's
something that came up in connection
with the sparkle queries and so on of
them being able to do path you know
being able to propagate down a path on a
graph um all right I think that's for
the future I mean I think that we should
add that by the way to the list of you
know kind of yeah
you
it's just a complicated thing to think
about um
okay
Sandler is talking about pre of
criterion and post of criterion yeah I
mean this whole question about pre and
post evaluation does come up in
connection with data set and I think we
haven't fully you know we haven't fully
penetrated
should work there but that's place where
it's gonna come up all right let's keep
going this is hopefully gonna be the
easier thing now less stability of DMS
functional I'd say yes so this is
something you I'm sorry your request is
recently and I realized that it's a bit
more difficult than I thought because
the the triple TMS list the TMS string
and from DMS work exactly like the date
corresponding functions latest rings at
least absolute time okay and the problem
is that because we support
simultaneously numbers and lists of
lists of numbers list ability becomes
complicated so in this example there was
there is the outer product we see that
the three functions from DMS DMS list
and DMS string are able to take the
three formats and they consistently
return the same thing so for example
dmoz lists can both take a number and a
list and for the list is written the
list itself and not go inside and I see
like dateless to do you know saying that
list does the same thing yes it takes
lists and lists and returns lists you
know it doesn't go inside and say oh I
have three absolute x that's the reason
why with late list etc we cannot have
stability
right well maybe we can't have it yeah I
mean is that your conclusion yes the
only thing we can support is for example
when we feed at your position our array
then because we know the structure we
can do things and I'd realize that it
doesn't work and prolly truth yeah this
should work
why not because there we do know
everything yeah why not
okay all right
and then this is this is some sort of
beginning of an idea which is yes so
from the very beginning version one
there was Parton position but they are
not inverses of each other and then
extract was introduced as true inverse
of position yep
but there is not yet a function that
plays the role of the inverse of part by
that I mean something that can return
what you would feed two part and the I
think the most useful for example is
finding the position of a of a soft
matrix yes if if it I mean it may not
well okay fair enough if there is such a
sub matrix like a block of identical
elements exactly or well they could even
be permitted and that's where my needs
come from because sometimes I have for
example our multiplication matrix
another one and I want to relate them I
know they are the same group it's just
that the elements were muted boy okay so
how do you find the interpolation yeah I
mean okay in the case of of position for
example we can't find sub matrices in
position right position is purely for
individual elements well at a given
level I mean in the tree it's you know
an individual row would work the
individual column will not work right
I mean how would you find a given column
of part we could do it okay you can
describe a column like all c'mon Joe I
understand well I mean there's always
find hot in another case that I think is
interesting is you can extract parts
from a sum but then it's quite difficult
to find a sub sum in a sum but what
would you even return because part is
very long so how would you return
something that is a single object yes
and of course with position the fact
that this thing might be several times
inside well maybe we can solve to kill
two birds with one stone I mean if we
have a part operator then we could
return the part operator that is the
extractor interesting yeah and if that
operator could take sequences like part
dance yeah well and then part operator
would be applied to an expression and
would get that part but now is that
useful I mean why not you know given
that you know I see that that becomes
useful because find part operator can
have a pattern here for example right do
you would have to say find this uh block
in this matrix well so that's what Expo
would be the matrix and then you'd have
this and then if that block exists then
it would return a part operator
corresponding so some mutant should
um okay so I mean but now if you want to
find a column let's say I want to find
this set of things let's say we have a
fine part operator um and I want to find
a column then what I have to do yeah you
know it's gonna have three arguments
it's got to find the thing to find and
it's got to have a a part pattern in a
sense it's got to say find it as a
column because otherwise you'd see the
level just to specify the level at which
you're looking for it is it just a level
or is it something more than that seems
a level Sid Venus well you couldn't have
a general part pattern like to find that
well no I mean to find only I want to
find it as a column but it's got to be
after column ten well I was expecting to
have some whatever part can described
already and part is is effectively a
tensor product of one dimensional things
so the level is full it worries about
well no sorry
it worries about multiple levels at the
same time yeah so it's more complicated
than a single okay by the way part
operator in our current world would be
equivalent operator of part would it not
yes yes but operator of part cannot
handle sequence it will have to be a
list of of their yeah well you are
already writing it us
well there I was yes but I mean in this
case wait a second this is the curry of
part two comma one of that is this gonna
fail yes because because leaves two on
one are different elements yes I
understand if I put in a list it's gonna
fail for other reasons it will extract
the whole matrix permitted yeah I
understand right so part operator could
have an extract like innards well maybe
a I don't know apart like in ins which
has been turned into a list so part two
would still work apart operator of two
would still work well no we could say
part operator is for an arc inside like
part is so we can say part operator of
alma - yeah I understand that but I
think what we want here if we have a
part pattern in fine part operator that
doesn't want to be very arcs
I'm still confused about the generality
of this part button I'm just saying that
whatever you going to return whatever
sequences you're going to return I mean
clearly there isn't a unique I mean like
all could be or it could be the list 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 or something tonight
so find part operator would have to be
would have to have some greediness to it
to make it you know do things like turn
big lists and to all's and stuff like
that but probably there in input we can
use all in output it would or whether
it's on the list why I don't think
that's the right thing I think it'd be
much more useful to have all their I
mean that's what a find would give it
license to do something somewhat
heuristic like that has a different
meaning depending on what it's been
applied to it does yeah it does but I
mean that's the question of what
generalization you're going to want I
mean this is most interesting if look if
if this was just being applied back to
the exact same thing again then why
would you do it at all you just you know
what you can find with this operator
right well yes but I was thinking of the
case in which you know something is
inside but you don't know what it is and
that's the interesting yeah but by the
time it's where it is then you don't
want this crazy part operator thing
wrapped around your your where it is
it's a sequence yes but I mean look the
alternative would be to have find part
and that returns a list boy which you'd
then have to say part operator of that
list apply to the thing you couldn't
give it to extract what is extract or
something different
well I mean one question is is find
apart actually writable you know in
other words is there an obvious calculus
of when you can use spans when you can
use all's stuff like this I would say
the first thing is to write the function
that returns only numbers and lists of
numbers and then there will be a second
step of trying to simplify this by the
way yeah but but actually look the to
find thing if it is the complete column
if the specification is like blank blank
for example it's pretty weird to give 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 to represent the blank bank
because the blank blank is really asking
for an all if on the other hand what you
give is ABCD then fine you can return 1
2 3 4 so I'm saying yes in some cases it
will be 1 2 3 4 but turn muted so we can
use holding why would it be permitted
yes this is the example I was saying
before if you have two multiplication
tables which are the same group but
different orders of elements you know
you can go from one to the other by
permutation
there are permutations so finding those
two permutations could be very different
in different access would be great I'm
very confused but I'm sorry you mean the
row permutations of the column
permutations yes in general it's four
groups it would be the same because it's
the same ordering for this for the same
list of elements yeah um okay well let's
come back to this hold on a second so
what you're saying is okay the two
things is you here apart operator and
for trying to I mean look why don't we
see why don't you see whether find part
and part operator make any sense or find
part operator returning apart operator
but do you think it should be very
significant should have a list inside it
I prefer to have more for example we
have indexed which unlike part uses a
list it so index is effectively like
part but with a list and it it stays
there happily symbolic and that's what
that was the main reason to introduce
indexed because part complaints about
part x-rays render is telling us to look
at slice and the function repository
let's go ahead and do that
of the tally production
[Applause]
this formatting is really sucky davin
another thing to complain about
I mean it's an operator fall apart I
have no great thrill um
I just don't really like sliced very
much because it's another metaphor you
know part slice what why would you call
it slice it's doing something that's
just like part and I agree with Ethan
that it's better to extend an overload
rather than to add symbols but sometimes
we you know unfortunately part is verax
and we can't have part of one argument
mean the operator form you know in a
perfect world if one were to replay
history we probably would have made X
double bracket a B turn into X part of
you know in a perfect world if if
history were to be replay we would
probably do this we probably say that
goes to part of X common list a B but
that's not all we did um
Ethan says sure you can but I'm not sure
what that's referring to unfortunately I
don't think you can
because while I agree okay so the claim
no it can't work because the operator
form of part part has yeah exactly
exactly you can't you can't make that
work unless you have a a list form of
what's inside apart because a first
argument yeah I just just can't work I
mean the and the problem is that this is
in a lighted form I mean in other words
you might have ended up with something
which is some and there may very well be
code that does this where you know if
it's a matrix it could have the first
element here but if it you know it's a
vector but if it's a scalar it has zero
extractors ie part of to ie to
you
I think part operator is the only
possibility
[Music]
you
you
and I don't think there's any plausible
syntax for it that would be yeah but
okay so imagine that an imagine fine
part operator returns a list two part
operators right that's what it's got to
do right yeah that's another good reason
to not have hum and then now to apply
that list two part operators right it's
a little bit funky right because you've
got a list of part operators um and
you're going to apply them to an expert
and what do we have to do here
well it's our friend the unused function
through well we could even think of
generalizing extract to do that because
the key point of extract is the multi
object nature yeah that's true but so
you're saying the alternative would be
extract expert comma part operator blah
blah blah blah but notice that part
operator I see when you write a piece of
code you can write part operator well so
what you would write is what would you
write you'd write something like select
hash gray
than two and then you would write at
star part operator is that right if you
want to get and then that thing I'll
stay s here applied to X Y would be that
which is the right thing um I'm
more typing to type hot operator than
hash sub-sub - although it's less um I
mean and one could imagine if this got
popular one could imagine some shorthand
for this thing well let's do the
experiment I mean this is a little bit
weird here but maybe brings through out
of the out of the shadows you know
somehow you know a lot of these
functional programming constructs right
I guess these higher-order I mean it's
it's it's really a question
it's an interesting world being built up
here and it's an interesting thing for
people to get experience with you know
using all these different things and
getting familiar with them it's kind of
a it's like so few universities now have
courses on functional programming but
there's a lot to teach um
anyway all right anything else we should
cover here I think it's worth trying to
implement some of the stuff and see
whether see whether this session makes
any sense
auto operator and fine pot operator um
okay I think we've achieved a bunch of
useful things here and thanks to folks
on the livestream I'm sorry I'm I'm I'm
coughing slightly and I'm still slightly
subdued because I was sick so probably
by the beginning of next week we will be
in full energy and we have many design
reviews coming up next week lots of
functionality for 12.1 so stay tuned
hope to see you all there
alright thank thanks a lot see you later
bye